eh bien cher celui de bataclan puisque
vous aimez ce genre là bas si mon grand
succès des disques excelsior le petit
berger de provence comme les monsieur
gestion nantes
c'était un petit berger de parents ce
qu'avait quitté sont deux pays
sa cavale et ses loisirs
son arrivée à paris si vous rencontrez
dans votre voyage un vieillard super de
près d'une forêt
il s'appelle prêts et les grandes vert
il pleure dans les plis pin ferme
chambre pas être celui qui s'est sauvée
non sans des as est honteux mais simon
honteux je vous en prie monsieur écouté
pendant le trajet des chansons que j'ai
recueillis sur le thème d'un enfant
égaré et un scandale monsieur on est
donc une sensibilité et si vous n'aimez
pas ça m'est donc dégoûtez pas les ans
et celle de ce gène sa j'adore
j'en pleure alors si vous en pleurer
monsieur en tant qu'artiste j'ai gagné
ne pavoisait pas trop vite pas il la
façon des façons de chanter une
complainte déchirant voyez vous parce
que vous n'aimez pas mon style dépouillé
confortée par là dedans y'a rien y
arrive à rien n'arrive à rien n'arrive à
rien puisque gardien damien vous n'aimez
pas la provence mathieu je n'aime pas la
famille n'est pas là pour moi monsieur
je venais vraiment je pense c'est une
boîte à cigares l'attend et quand je
respire dans mes poumons
quand j'ai spector mistral qui en sort
il est prévu que je n'aime pas les
musées mais pas les moussons je n'ai que
des costumes curley décollage orages je
pleure car c'est un peu ma vie que vous
avez chanté en vous brossant rubini mais
si il y à 20 ans mon fils sur un coup de
tête parti et depuis j'attends monsieur
j'attends qu'on sonne à ma porte sur
monture gicla sujet plate car malgré mon
cynisme unique
je suis un grand souvenir oui monsieur
je suis partie un jeu aussi un coup de
tête j'ai quitté ma chaumières en 1903
en trois endroits
oui tu monte à paris pour réussir vous
voilà comme on dit et maintenant je
chante ma triste histoire pour survivre
n'aurait pas un mauvais traitements ont
certainement s'était excusé moi vous ne
pouvez pas savoir et toutes les nuits
monsieur je revois les vannes on les bat
nombreux lots de barbentane
parental près de la baie dont l'un était
au la times avec la presse et le mas le
nord la zone avait simplement se mettre
au chant du mien genre mougnol jo alfred
podium mais jean alfred bougnol c'est
moi brody mon fils mon bélier non papa